love you I love you thank you so much
are you kidding thank you for doing this
this is great this will make the whole
night special you know the druber it
gets you guys I heard I heard I've seen
the drooper I'm happy to be in the
druber I'd like to start this with the
tradition have you ever farted under the
covers uh constantly a dutch oven I know
the Dutch oven I don't wave it if
Jackie's near me I don't I try to go
easy on her I pee now Drew literally
five a night I don't think that's
healthy but while I'm walking there I go
you know what let me take care of that
other thing too when I blast one out
well that is a perfect time
I don't even know how this happened I've
been hearing about being an old man ever
since that came out by the way I wanted
to do the cover of AARP you're too young
for that I'm too young you little baby
if you had one movie that you had to
choose one movie gets to represent like
you know when they put the Time Capsule
together like in 50 First Dates I made
you a tape every day remember that no I
don't remember that
you're good you're good yeah what would
be your one you only get one so the
movie that kind of sums up everything
yeah yeah I worked with this young lady
one time I met her at The Newsroom Cafe
she came in she had stylish hair a
little pinkish
she came in we jammed on a movie idea we
got together we shot it we
had the best time ever and I said want
to see that one and we call it
The Wedding Singer that wasn't allowed
to sing Grow Old With You to Drew before
we sang it not at once I said I wrote
that that song I don't want to hear it
that's my reaction on film for the first
time I did that with forgetful Lucy too
that's right that's right yeah oh
forgetful Lucy and then the Dolphins did
the perfect like heart dive so then the
Dolphins were like oh we like this let's
give it a good ending guys
say you go to the Past lives Pavilion
and you find out that you were someone
in history that makes you so psyched who
would you have been who was heroic
Lincoln would be nice yes
yes great great choice did a lot of
great things for the world
and he was a lot skinnier than me
I'll go with Lincoln who would you be by
the way oh that's the one I asked you
that no I hadn't thought of it I think
about it right now I know who you who
first words that come to Lizzie Borden
who's that Lizzie Borden Lizzie Borden
was like a Fame
and she
no
for real I feel like I would have to be
someone with a sense of humor oh okay
you could be Gilda she was great sweet
like you be killed yeah and her and
cheating wife exactly maybe we're kind
of like Gene and Gilda that would be
pretty good Drew oh yeah through that
story
amen Bobby what is one food that no
matter what and I mean no matter what
you you will not eat it tuna fish
really I can't stay I have tuna sushi
but tuna fish in my house my wife knows
this everybody knows it it's the most
disgusting smell to me I get nuts my
father would make tuna sandwiches in me
I'd be like Dad did you have to do that
to be like get out of the room I'm
eating my tuna and yeah it would have
made me sick you like tuna sandwiches I
do like tuna good for you Sushi and did
you ever eat one right before giving me
a kiss on one of these days
I think you made a joke that I smelled
or tasted like tuna fish in one of our
kissing scenes I think I think it's like
it was a go-to joke for you I want to
say Blended all right maybe I've heard
you say I can see it in your lips tuna
fish
you do he always did have a little Tuna
thing going on mine's goats cheese
say you work at Apple and the eggplant
Emoji has been Stripped Away because
everybody knows it's an emoji yes okay
and you have now got to pick the next
vegetable to slyly slide in as the new
Emoji which vegetable are you going with
I guess carrot or uh depending if I'm
feeling shy maybe to shrimp
[Music]
can I introduce you to a very special
person Ronnie pleased to meet you good
to see you my man thanks for driving
Ronnie Ronnie is my mobile
review hustle I will say it's an
exceptional movie thank you yes it's
very hard though it's motivating yeah
there's also a lot of life lessons in
there yes and this movie has made my
list of top three Sports movies yes
Remember the Titans and Rocky are my
other two that's big that means a lot
both those movies are incredible thanks
Ronnie I had a great time making that
thing and it was fun to make one without
Drew to be honest with you
what is one thing in comedy that is off
limits to you and I mean a real boundary
oh wow I don't even think about that I I
say I have said things in the past that
I wish I hadn't somebody's gonna get
hurt somewhere son there are perfect
jokes that include everybody and that
everyone just goes oh my God I'm so
happy knowing you know when you make a
joke that happens to fall in that
category it's amazing but that's that's
not a guarantee there's a lot of stuff
that you're in think straight and so and
so is upset right now
I wish that didn't happen even when
you're at the dinner table you say a
joke you look at everyone laughing
you'll see one person tuned out you're
like what did I say wrong to that person
you know okay that's been happening to
me in the audience lately
no I swear Drew my when I was like 17 or
18 I used to go on stage
comedy clubs in Brooklyn
I'd go on the comic strip up Uptown on
the Upper East Side here and I would go
up there and I'd look out and if there
was 15 people in the crown and there was
one person not laughing I would start
zeroing in on that person and sometimes
I would get aggressive and be like you
all right bud and
integer one of my first managers he was
a casting agent he managed me when I was
young and he said you gotta stop being
so worried about everybody that you're
you're being everyone was having a nice
time until you kind of yelled at that
guy why would you do that and it took me
a while to get over just going all right
somebody's not going to like them let me
just keep going Sadie and sunny you are
so not invited to like Bob Mitzvah yeah
best title that's a good one yes did you
wait until you thought they were old
enough because they've always been doing
cameos in the movies yes just something
that happened it was pretty organic and
they're very that wasn't a part that was
my that was a foot noise
hahaha
oh my one more
all right here you go
anyways when this book came into our
office and everybody loved this idea and
I mean this is what they want to do they
want to act they like it and they watch
good acting and they love you and they
think I'm fine sometimes
my kids say to me what do you think your
best thing on your face is like what are
you thinking they go nothing but that's
kids Olive literally told me that like I
don't know how to write an s that my s's
I've always been horrible I remember
that back in the day I was gonna
originally change the title of Wedding
Singer to wedding anger across the US
your ass was pathetic remember when 51st
dates was 50 First kisses yeah too many
yeses we had to get rid of it now I know
that you had hip surgery left one when
you send me the text of the picture and
your like leg was up yeah and you you
were watching the show yeah yeah I watch
your show all the time mornings I get to
see you see how happy you are how the
energy you give off to everybody to
everyone on the show to the audience you
help me get the pilot we did that to you
and Cameron yep by the way Cameron will
you say hi to Cameron I haven't seen
Cameron in many years her and I did
discuss remaking Planes Trains and
Automobiles and I was like well you know
Adam and I talk about that but yeah I'd
let you do that well also I want to play
John Candy well I you could do a good
candy you know who used to do candy the
best barley when he would walk around
the office and do lines from Planes
Trains you remember hanging out with all
of us at when I had some giant party at
my house I remember looking over the
balcony and it was like Spade Farley
Rock everyone the coolest people in the
world we're about to go into your sag
town hall right now I love you so we get
out come on Barrymore thank you thanks
Ronnie thanks guys
don't forget to leave me a review
[Music]